okay I have to pat myself on the back a
little bit today but also kind of cry
because this is so horrible I've been
saying for months Donald Trump is not
married to Fox News Fox News didn't
support Donald Trump early in the 2016
Republican primary in fact it was sort
of the opposite
early on Fox News was opposed to Donald
Trump they eventually came around and
I've said that they could bail at any
time a few months ago Donald Trump
started sending some sort of light
attacks against Fox News Shepard Smith
was a target the weekend anchors on Fox
News were targets and I told you Trump
could abandon Fox News and Fox News
because the bit could abandon Donald
Trump and if this happens watch out
because Donald Trump is going to start
promoting an even crazier channel called
Oh a n1 American News or sometimes it's
oay and n1 American news network this is
my clip okay from months ago talking
about this Fox News is not necessarily
going to stick with Trump they're about
profit and right-wing propaganda in a
general sense Trump might be the vehicle
for that propaganda but he also might
not and just to prepare you if Trump and
Fox have a falling out you need to know
that Donald Trump's network of choice is
going to become this absolutely wacked
out thing called Oh a n the one America
news network or one American news check
it out online but not with kids in the
room and not close to meal times because
it is truly it'll it'll turn your
stomach but Oh a n is where Trump will
go if ultimately he abandons Fox News as
the propaganda vehicle of choice and
right on cue
yesterday Donald Trump tweeting quote
watching fake news CNN is better than
watching Shepard Smith the lowest rated
show on Fox News actually whenever
possible I turn to Oh a and n and I'm
actually getting credit for this one my
predictions are normally so bad I'm
actually glad to be getting some credit
for this one I noticed on the subreddit
yesterday didn't David predict this with
a link to Donald Trump's tweet so it's
all fun and games and okay I got one
right finally after getting so many
wrong but this is a really dangerous
channel this is even more dangerous
actually than Fox with the exception
that it
a much smaller audience for now so I
guess in a way that makes it less
dangerous
they Fernau only have about 380,000
YouTube subscribers we are just one show
that's an entire network and we have
about double that so it's small for now
but they're growing quickly Donald Trump
putting the spotlight on them and saying
that it's a good channel is going to
give them significantly more support
this is a channel that promoted the Seth
Ridge conspiracy theory this is a
channel that promoted a conspiracy
theory about 17-year old activist David
Hogg they pushed the story about Hillary
Clinton funding an Tifa this is I mean
Fox News is bad and it's very well
funded this is bad and this is what the
president is increasingly promoting oh
the OE n also published smears of George
Soros but like I probably didn't have to
tell you that that's almost a given for
these channels obviously they're
smearing George Soros it's it's it's
almost like a rite of passage
I looked yesterday after Trump tweeted
this at some of the very toxic pro-trump
internet enclaves that I don't even want
to name they're thrilled that Donald
Trump is now promoting oen because as
far as they're concerned Fox isn't
right-wing enough for them and it's not
pro Trump enough for them this is going
to be an insane election season and this
also relates to why we need to be
thinking of media in the context of who
are we funding through our cable
subscriptions
and in other ways maybe without even
knowing it and thinking about how we can
make sure that our dollars even the ones
that we are offhandedly spending in a
cable subscription aren't going to
support some of these channels espousing
views that we find completely deplorable
and disgusting let me know what you
think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
make sure also to follow me on twitch at
twitch.tv slash david pakman I ended up
having an impromptu debate with Stephen
destiny Bunnell yesterday about TPP
which we'll be uploading to Facebook
later a lot of great stuff happening
over at twitch.tv slash David Pakman
today's sponsor is Skillshare and I'm
excited to tell you that everybody in
our audience is getting two entire
months of free
access the Skillshare when you click the
link underneath this video skill shares
the site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]